hi this is the second of a 12-part
series of short videos
based on my new book beyond order
12 more rules for life each video
features one of the rules
as well as a paragraph from the chapter
based on that rule
rule two is imagine who you could be and
then
aim single-mindedly at that
this paragraph is taken from a chapter
sub-section entitled
who are you and who could you be
an unforgettable story captures the
essence of humanity
and distills communicates and clarifies
it
bringing what we are and what we should
be into focus
it speaks to us motivating the attention
that inspires
imitation we learn to see and act in the
manner of the heroes of the stories that
captivate us
these stories call to capacities that
lie deep within our nature but might
still never develop
without that call we are dormant
adventurers
lovers leaders artists and rebels but
need to discover that we are
all those things by seeing the
reflection of such patterns in dramatic
and literary form
that is part of being a creature that is
part nature and part culture
an unforgettable story advances our
capacity to understand our behavior
beyond habit and expectation toward an
imaginative
and then verbalized understanding
such a story presents us in the most
compelling manner with the ultimate
adventure
the divine romance and the eternal
battle between good and evil
all this helps us clarify our
understanding of moral and
immoral attitude personal and social
this can be seen everywhere and always
question who are you or at least
who could you be answer
part of the eternal force that
constantly confronts the terrible
unknown voluntarily part of the eternal
force that transcends naivety
and becomes dangerous enough in a
controlled manner
to understand evil and bearded in its
lair
and part of the eternal force that faces
chaos and turns it into productive order
or the takes order that has become too
restrictive
reduces it to chaos and renders it
productive once again
and all of this being very difficult to
understand consciously but
vital to our survival is transmitted in
the form of the stories that we cannot
help but attend to
and it is in this manner that we come to
apprehend what is of value
what we should aim at and what we could
be
beyond order will be available in print
and audio format
on march 2nd 2021 but can be pre-ordered
before that
details can be found at
jordanbpeterson.com
a more precise url can be found in the
description of this video